yo the new 2k Builder is crazy and so
much to do so many possibilities bro
this is crazy I think I'm gonna make a
job a rent build man I think I'm gonna
make a Jordan build this is crazy I have
entered the chat sir yes sir Welcome
Back Sir so I see you guys have been
enjoying the new 2k Builder huh yes sir
yes sir it's so many possible yeah yeah
very exciting very exciting well I'm
gonna need you guys to go ahead and
check the group chat for me Roger that
sir you'll see a screenshot in there of
the build I need all of you to make as
soon as possible a non scoring rebound
to point guard shots Defender third well
I plan on taking all the shots this year
what so you guys don't have to worry
about scoring anything like that but sir
just make sure you play some good
defense for me and rebound all my shots
sir this is unacceptable this bill won't
be able to do anything
I would strip your rank away so quick in
the friend group you will never play a
game again in your life if you ever talk
to me like that again
disregard sir disregard we are buying
our VC now and we'll begin grinding our
bills as soon as possible